okay so you know one question that I get
like pre I guess pretty often is people
want to know my background they want to
know how I became a conservative and
it's really interesting because if I
take a personality test it actually says
I'm super liberal like it says I have a
90-something percent chance of being a
liberal and I guess like some of the
traits or the qualities that I have um
like liberals tend to have some very
creative you know that's why you see all
the hippies and the Vans
um they're usually more liberal you know
I'm very open so I'm open to new
experiences
um I'm low I think I'm low in
conscientiousness which like tends to go
more with the Liberals and so a lot of
people have asked me like how did you
become conservative and um I would say
growing up like
I wasn't as conservative as I am today
but I've always like leaned right so you
know I've always been pro-life pretty
much I've always
um I mean I'm a woman so there's you
know I've had moments but overall like
I've always been pro-life I haven't
believed in high taxes and I would say I
was more of a Libertarian than a
patriarchist growing up like I used to
love watching Ben Shapiro Candice Owens
like I I loved watching The Daily wire
in high school
um and but sometimes occasionally I
would get a liberal idea right so you
know when BLM first came through when I
was in college
um I remember I would go home and like
repeat a talking point maybe from BLM
but the person that really made me
conservative was my father because any
time that I would come home with a
little liberal of an idea just a little
bit
um I would come home to my dad and tell
him
and he would just sit down and my dad's
like the calmest guy ever so he would
never get angry never get mad but he
would just like sit down and have a
conversation with me about why I was
wrong
um and I remember one thing that he um
he pointed out to me he said my first
name's Hannah for those of you that
don't know so he said Hannah uh two
dollars and one dollar out
and I said dad what do you mean he says
you put two dollars into something you
make one dollar out
and um you can only have so many of
those programs before you run out of
money
and this really stuck with me because
you know I've always been a more like a
compassionate person so I never wanted
to well I know you guys you guys might
not believe me today right but but I
actually
um but like even when I was a kid I
remember like I saved up all my money
for it was it was so funny
um I I saved up like 300 bucks back then
for for um I think I wanted a dog or
something I think I wanted a dog and it
was so funny because I went to school
and that was like when the tsunami
happened
um in I don't remember where it was I
was quite young but I gave like my my uh
my money to the teacher
um for for the tsunami it was kind of
funny my parents didn't even know so you
know I'll invest in like people that I
like or like I've always you know had
that
I I don't know where
compassion I got I know you guys might
not believe me but I swear but and you
know at some points like I could see
like some of the liberal ideas would
start to kind of make sense to me you
know you feel bad for people that grow
up in terrible situations you want to
help them out
um but my dad really would just break
down like why all of these programs are
not helping people and really like the
biggest form of compassion you could you
can give someone is to Mentor them or
coach them and there were so many people
my dad just like mentored or helped like
like my dad um
uh one of his employees like worked for
him for 20 years and my dad like this
was just like a couple weeks ago he he
helped her move like he literally helped
her and her family move like that just
the type of guy my dad is but he he
explained to me that like all these free
programs like they are not actually
compassion because they don't help
people move up economically and so you
know when Trump ran the first time I
wasn't overly political
um so I I didn't vote I had like a uh I
had some like I was always intro like I
watched the media but I just wasn't
crazy involved so I think I had a test
or something the first time he ran so I
didn't vote for anybody
um but when I saw the positive things
that he did in the country you know and
and this stuff wasn't even like I was I
was following super close but I just saw
people were making more money around me
uh people tended to have more money in
their bank accounts but my parents
business was doing better people I knew
that had businesses were doing better
and it there was just some sort of like
hope in the country where it wasn't just
a career politician and growing up I
didn't see that hope under the Obama
Administration I didn't see that hope
under the Clinton Administration like
Trump was different and you know that's
why in the next election that I would
argue was stolen but you know I I voted
for him and there there's just been like
a hopelessness a bit the last couple of
years when
people the future just doesn't look
bright and under trump it was different
so you know that's why I support Trump
in this election like people have asked
me who I'm voting for I really do like
Trump I'm open I think that the policies
that Trump passed helped America people
had more money in their bank accounts I
think the policies that Trump passed
really just helped Middle America they
helped the average guy and I think we
need to push
candidates that are here to help the
average men and the average families in
America so that's the story of how I
became conservative and why I support
Trump so
you know and I also like that Trump just
really doesn't stand for any of this
craziness